jacques derrida
was one of the most famous controversial
but also wise figures
in recent french intellectual life he
invented a way of doing philosophy
that he called deconstruction which
fundamentally altered our understanding
of many academic fields
especially literary studies derrito was
born in 1930 in el biar
a suburb of algiers in what was then
french colonial algeria
his family were jews his father a
salesman for a local wine firm
he was initially slow at school and
harvard dreams of becoming a
professional soccer player
in 1942 under new laws enacted by the
collaborationist french vishi regime
derrida like all other jewish children
was forcibly excluded from his lysey
and spent a lot of his time at home with
his mother he suffered greatly from the
anti-semitism of algeria's majority
muslim population
and was deeply marked by the experience
of having been in an inferior position
at the nexus of three different
religions judaism christianity and islam
all of which claimed to speak the truth
none of which knew how to treat the
others
with particular respect in 1949 just
turned 19
derrida traveled to paris to take up a
place at the prestigious ecole normale
superior
he was a brilliant student but in an odd
position
highly privileged in terms of education
but utterly at the margins in
metropolitan france
in his status as an algerian jew though
derrida was not an autobiographical
writer
it's hard not to read his work as a
highly abstract response
to his first-hand knowledge of bigotry
and exclusion
it was from the late 1960s onwards that
derrida began to develop the ideas that
made his name
in time he became a celebrity
intellectual around europe and america
he was hugely glamorous a good-looking
man with great taste in raincoats and
haircuts
he had a rich diverse and complex love
life
in 1980 he was arrested on a wholly
false drug smuggling charge
but was supported by the french
president and politicians from both left
and right
he loved playing snooker and devoted
most of his afternoons to the game
which he played with exemplary skill he
died in 2004
from pancreatic cancer at the age of 74.
derrida wrote 40 books all of them
abstruse and subtle
but his importance for us can be
revealed by examining three
initially odd sounding terms he often
used deconstruction
aporia and logocentrism behind the
high-flow vocabulary
lies some crucially important ideas
deconstruction is the word most commonly
associated with derrida
he used it to describe the way he went
about thinking though when other people
started using this term he quite often
felt they'd misunderstood what he meant
by it
essentially deconstruction means
dismantling our excessive loyalty to any
idea
and learning to see the aspects of the
truth that might lie buried in its
opposite
it was in 1967 that derider published
his first major book
of grammatology its overt topic is
admittedly rather strange
even tedious derrida was convinced that
western philosophers since socrates
had systematically privileged speech
which was seen as authentic
communication
over writing which was regarded as a
mere transcript of what people might say
a second-hand report lacking the
interaction and truthfulness that comes
with conversation
in itself this hardly feels like an
urgent issue
but the drama of derrida's work came
from the bigger idea he developed from
this claim
his overarching ambition was to advance
a vast
troubling proposition that once we begin
to examine it closely
almost all our thinking is riddled with
a false
that is unjustified and unhelpful
privileging
of one thing over another speech is
privileged over writing
reason over passion men at least for
long periods
over women words over pictures sight
over touch derrida's core point was that
this privileging
involves a failure to see the merits and
value of the supposedly
lesser part of the equation derrida was
not so much making the nihilistic point
that everything is worthless
he was stressing that the neglected
counterparts in some of our key
oppositions
are worthy of love and attention over
his 40 books
derrida deconstructed a range of key
binary terms
reason versus passion masculinity versus
femininity
profit versus generosity high culture
versus low culture
his hope was that we could learn to live
more intelligently with some of the
conflicts that lay beneath these terms
that we could come to see that both
sides were onto something
that both were a bit wrong that both
needed each other
and that the tension between would by
necessity always prove irrevocable
it might look as if derider was always
using deconstruction to attack tradition
and the free market and to promote a
left-wing egalitarian agenda
but he was a great deal more subtle than
this for example in his deconstruction
of the idea of equality
derrida proposed that the assertion that
equality is always better than
inequality
though this might be a modern liberal
axiom is in fact
unstable and obscure and he pointed out
that some of the best
human situations we know are obviously
not examples of equality in action
derrida a devoted professor and father
wrote beautifully and at length
about the relationship between pupils
and teachers
and children and parents to deconstruct
an idea
is to show that it's confused and
riddled with logical defects
and that we must keep its messiness
constantly in mind
derrida was criticizing our tendency to
imagine that behind every problem
lies somewhere a good and neat solution
we offer him creatures destined to live
our lives
without clear answers and that the
craving for them
is at the root of our troubles he wanted
to cure us of our love of crude
simplicity
and to make us more comfortable with a
permanently oscillating nature of wisdom
for instance he argued that we might be
rightly confused about the merits of
capitalism and socialism
or the relationship between love and sex
but that we should never rush to
conclusions around these topics
there are useful things to be said on
both sides of these equations
to conclude that capitalism is either
splendid or sinful or that love and sex
are either
very closely linked or have nothing much
to do with one another
is to avoid grappling with the fraud and
kaleidoscopic nature of reality
being confused and uncertain around such
concepts
isn't a sign of weakness or stupidity it
is for derrida the central mark
of maturity there it is tactic was to
glamorize this condition
and to give it a positive ring which is
why he brought back into use a beautiful
greek word
aporia meaning impasse or puzzlement
he was proposing aporia as a state we
should feel proud to know
and to visit on a regular basis
confusion and doubt are not
embarrassing dead ends in the deridian
world view
they are simply evidence of the
adulthood of the mind
one of derrida's chief targets of
criticism was a way of thinking that he
called
logocentrism by which he understood an
over-hasty
naive devotion to reason logic and clear
definition
underpinned by a faith in language as
the natural and best way to communicate
derrida who loved music and art stressed
that many of the most important things
we feel
can never be neatly expressed in words
spoken or written
as a logocentric tends to forget an
instance of logocentrism
which particularly interested derrida
was the prestige
of the idea of iq which measures
primarily a person's ability to solve
logical puzzles
but which largely ignores many other
qualities of mind
for example telling us very little about
a person's capacity for friendship for
being a parent
for having fun or managing their
emotions for derrida certain people
might not be so brilliant at completing
geometrical sequences
but that would tell us very little about
their skill at making a success of a
marriage a business
a holiday or a party all of whose
importance derrida
understood well as an esteemed professor
who lectured in the world's best
universities
derrida who was also the snooker and
football loving algerian jew
was casting doubts on the entire
foundations of the modern
intellectual worldview like many
important thinkers
derrida can be cherished as a corrective
to certain excessive attitudes
in his case an overzealous devotion to
reason and clear-cut
answers derrida didn't want to remove
all hierarchies
he knew it was right that kindness
should be privileged over cruelty
wit over dullness generosity over
meanness
but he also understood how often we
unwittingly dismiss
things people and ideas when their
opposites bask
in what might be an arbitrary status at
his best
derrida is a voice of modesty and
patience asking us to see
what might be a value in those ideas we
too easily overlook
and to get curious about why it might be
nice to be always
even if only for a little while on the
other side
of any debate
you